so I got all my forces now so now I'm
ready to say what's happening on each of
my excessive movement okay so vertically
I guess we want to stay in the center of
our Lantern what's happening vertically
it's stationary so therefore I've got a
vertical force here vertical force there
so i'm going to write them down to ya na
+ coz theta + g which is negative that's
a net force of zero because it is
stationary as you just say so you got
and coz theta equals mg that's fight
horizontally this is us actually making
the turn I've got you'd hope uniform
circular motion at least that's the
design okay so what am I going to write
here what would you like me to put down
Andy de- n st. viateur pause what so
here I've got n sine theta facing that
way now whether you put a positive or a
negative is somewhat up to you I would
define I think it's just consistent all
along we've been saying that toward the
center is negative and away from the set
up numbers getting bigger radius getting
bigger is positive so I like to write
this and that we're saying that that
will do everything right this is our
negative so we could go Empire Omega
squared but since it's going to be more
useful to in this context to go with be
rather Omega I'm gonna write this as MV
squared on off okay so i would just now
fix up the signs that I know where they
come from okay and let's give these two
guys names it's quite a one-in-two now
just like before like say with circular
motion in the first place or the conical
pendulum resistor motion all that what
do you think is a natural question to
ask off of these equations yeah okay
it's like look it goes together right
that's an obvious choice for Therese
there's no wine you like oh look ends
will cancel that's kind of nice that's
sort of what's happening if I don't
worry about the normal force what's
what's independent a little more force
and secondly remember i said to you a
rope design is kind of kind of want to
know what this um what this theater is
right so they're like how far should I
push this on so if i divide to buy one
that'll get cosine in the right spot so
i'm going to go to 2/1 ends will cancel
I've been left with tan feet up on the
left-hand side what do I get on the
right this divided by this M is canceled
v squared is still on the top and G is
on the bottom okay wonderful now this
gives us two things depending on what
you're after okay remember i was just
saying oh if you're a road designer you
want to be able to set up the embankment
so that it will be for whatever optimum
speed there is the right angle okay so
there's no friction so therefore from
this what am I going to have to do if I
want any angle
yeah I just go via equals tan inverse V
scoops v square on our G okay so it's
like okay if I've some predefined
velocity what's it supposed to be grabby
which take that is known for their
pretty much and i know it's meant to go
that far out that's how far my turn
should be this is how far i will incline
the embankment okay that's good or
alternatively you might not be the road
designer right you might be the person
driving along and you can see it you
know turning off in the distance so
maybe feed our and the radius of the
road and gravity have already been
decided for you right so it's up to you
to pick the right speed so all I have to
do here is yeah i'm going to multiply by
RG and then i'm going to take the square
root do you see that i'm only interested
in positive water you obviously so i'm
going to say V equals the square root of
R Gean 10 feet up haha so from here this
is these are two you know valuable
things to solve so that's really really
good and pretty much I none this is our
nice perfect situation